cop 26 in glasgow there's no
underestimating the scale of this
climate summit but what's at stake
greater still and the negotiations
difficult
the host greeting dozens of world
leaders
working in tandem with old reliable
allies no longer enough
the pm with a pointed warning if glasgow
fails it all fails
it's possible that there's only one
civilization in the milky way galaxy
the responsibility weighs heavily on
these leaders the world's in their hands
and he knows that look at his face
it's one minute to midnight on that
doomsday clock and we need
to act now
if we don't get serious
about climate change today
it will be too late for our children to
do so tomorrow
decisions made here in the next two
weeks will decide the future for
generations to come on this the
president of the european commission
telling me she agrees with the pm
how much is at stake here and how
confident are you that we can make real
progress on climate change
this is a moment of truth and we really
have to step up
it was good that g20 came up with a
united position of 1.5 degrees celsius
we want to reach and the climate finance
because the g20 are 80
of the emitters worldwide but now we
have to get concrete because action has
to happen now in this decade
and it has been for many decades
generations even that the royal family
has campaigned for climate change
tonight her majesty the queen unable to
be in glasgow in person on doctor's
advice sent a message of encouragement
it is a source of great pride to me
that the leading role my husband played
in encouraging people to protect our
fragile planet
lives on through the work of our eldest
son charles and his eldest son william
i could not be more proud of them
i for one hope that this conference will
be one of those rare occasions
where everyone will have the chance to
rise above the politics of the moment
and achieve true statesmanship
not only is this a gigantic summit it's
also a giant pressure pot in which the
world's biggest polluters come face to
face with the country's dealing with the
consequences whose very existence is
threatened by global warming the leaders
who are here hope that in the next two
weeks they can agree concrete actions to
truly begin to tackle climate change but
they need russia brazil and china to
step up and those leaders aren't here
prime minister modi of india has at
least turned up but he's perhaps not
stepped up enough the world's third
biggest admitter committing to net zero
but not for five more decades
2017 by 2070
india will achieve the target of net
zero emissions
india also calling on rich countries to
provide one trillion dollars in climate
finance to developing countries the u.s
president says he's already doing his
bit
the united states will be able to meet
the ambitious target i said
the leaders summit and climate back in
april reducing u.s emissions
by 50 to 52 percent below
2005
levels by 2030.
we'll demonstrate to the world the
united states is not only back at the
table
but hopefully leading by the
power of our example
day one and thumbs up as this leader at
least puts forward a concrete plan
every little helps but differences
remain and with china still missing in
action team world still struggling beth
rigby sky news glasgow